[Musique]
David Johnston est un homme qui a servi
ce pays de façon
extraordinaire toute sa vie
il était reconnu par des politiciens de
tous les différents partis comme étant
un homme de qualité et d'intégrité
juste un Trudeau à la défense de David
Johnston dont l'intégrité et la rigueur
sont sans reproches dit-il le passé du
nouveau rapporteur spécial nommé par le
Premier ministre particulièrement ces
liens avec la Fondation Trudeau ont
alimenté cette semaine les critiques des
parties d'opposition
c'est juste un trou d'eau qui a semé le
cas le chaos dans notre démocratie et
c'est aussi lui qui a décidé de nommer
un nombre de la Fondation trou d'eau un
organisme qui a été financé par Pékin
pour faire
ce travail de rapporteur
Justin Trudeau choisit encore un proche
être proche de quelqu'un au point d'être
défini par le Premier ministre lui-même
comme étant un ami de la famille permet
de croire qu'on aura un petit gêne avant
de faire le contraire de ce que notre
ami souhaite
[Musique]
peut-il calmer les choses pour le
gouvernement dans le dossier de
l'ingérence étrangère voyons voir ce
qu'on pense mes collaborateurs avec
Gaston gay et animateurs de midi info
ici première
magazine d'actualité Michel CEG est
chroniqueur politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour bonjour
à certains postes dans mes gouverneur
général par les conservateurs la
Fondation Trudeau c'est pas une sur
salle du Parti libéral c'est une
fondation lucratif un moment donné tout
le monde un moment donné un lien avec un
petit ou un autre alors personne qui
remet en question vraiment sauf pour des
raisons partisanes la compétence de
Monsieur Johnson ce qui est en cause
c'est pourquoi est-ce que le premier
ministre prend une autre personne une
tierce personne pour décider de quelque
chose qui est la prérogative du Premier
ministre c'est-à-dire de faire une
enquête publique ça c'est contestable et
ça et on peut très certainement avoir un
débat là-dessus sur la personnalité de
Monsieur Johnston bien franchement je
trouve pas que c'est un mauvais choix
c'est une mauvaise idée que de l'avoir
je leur apporter un spécial non oui
entre le choix et les Chantal
j'ai absolument aucun doute ayant vu la
feuille de route de
Johnston qu'on a quand même vu aller
pendant longtemps j'ai absolument aucun
doute qu'au moment où il va faire ses
recommandations son premier souci ce
sera pas de se dire est-ce que je peux
en faire une qui fera pas de dommage
politique
à Justin Trudeau mon ami et mon ex
voisin
on lui fait en fait un mauvais procès
alors qu'on devrait faire
plutôt un procès au Premier ministre
pour cette idée qu'il délègue sa
responsabilité à quelqu'un d'autre comme
si tout à coup comme premier ministre il
pouvait pas prendre des décisions
écoutez pierre poillière la mémoire
extraordinaire
si tout ce que Monsieur Johnson avait
fait dans la vie c'est piloté la
Fondation Trudeau qui en passant
s'occupe de donner des bourses
des étudiants et au sein de laquelle
comme mentor d'un étudiant j'ai
fréquenté aussi bien Denise Bombardier
était un patrimoine quand même mais qui
est un député fondateur du Parti
réformiste alors on passera pour les
accointances mais
on lui fait ce mauvais procès alors
qu'on devrait plutôt s'interroger sur la
décision du Premier ministre de s'en
remettre à quelqu'un d'autre pour
prendre une décision j'ai écouté ce
matin vendredi matin c'est le 20e
anniversaire de la décision de gens
chrétien de pas aller en Irak un c'est
payé pour prendre ce genre de décision
difficile là ça inclut la décision
nettement plus simple de décider si on
fait ou non une révision judiciaire ou
une commission d'enquête publique ou
rien du tout sur un dossier comme
ingénieur chinois
monsieur Trudeau de gagner du temps ce
que c'est la bonne marche à suivre parce
que est-ce que c'est pas plus de majeur
pour lui d'aller dans cette direction là
parce qu'il est le plus difficile pour
David Johnston c'est que écoutez on lui
donne un mandat où il peut à peu près
faire tout ce qu'il veut c'est à dire
recommander une commission d'enquête
publique non public pourrait faire un
processus de de révision judiciaire et
pourrait recommander autre chose dans la
réalité c'est que le temps est tellement
été long entre l'annonce du rapporteur
spécial en fait même le temps est-il
très long entre le début de la
controverse le moment où on a dit qu'on
allait nommé un rapporteur spécial et le
moment où on le connaît ici il s'est
passé presque un mois très long mois où
il y a eu beaucoup de révélations de
sorte que même si David Johnston a comme
mandat de recommander ce qu'il veut en
réalité peut-il vraiment recommander ce
qu'il veut parce que je pense
qu'actuellement on l'a un peu mis dans
une boîte parce que s'il recommande
autre chose qu'une enquête publique
automatiquement on va dire tout ça pour
ça les parties d'opposition avaient
raison on essaie de de ménager le
gouvernement en place c'est comme si
David Johnstone acceptait un mandat où
il est menotté il n'a presque pas le
choix de recommander quelque chose
d'assez costaud même si le juge que
peut-être il y aurait d'autres façons de
le faire peut-il vraiment aller là sans
soulever de tempête politique et donc
miner le processus de révision je suis
pas certain j'ai comme l'impression
qu'on a un peu écrit d'avance et
conclusion parce qu'on a pris trop de
temps parce qu'on était divorcé et parce
qu'on a essayé de jouer l'horloge du
côté du gouvernement ça pourrait se
retourner contre eux et ne pas avoir le
choix de déclencher l'enquête publique
quand un jour on va remettre son rapport
monsieur Johnson j'ai vu un chemin de
tête Chantal qu'est-ce qu'il a gagné
dans le fond monsieur Trudeau
maintenant je sais pas si j'imagine
qu'il y a quelque chose à gagner à part
peut-être du temps mais il y a des gens
qui ont comparé sa démarche à celle de
Steven un peu rappelez-vous il y avait
fait appel à la même personne un autre
chose que Pierre polliès semble avoir
oublié pour établir le cadre de
l'enquête sur les relations de Bryan ma
journée
la commission mais il y a une grosse
différence monsieur Harper avait dit il
va y avoir une enquête
et il y avait demandé à quelqu'un
d'autre que lui pour tout sorte de
raisons de proximité de conflits
d'intérêt de malaise de définir les
termes de et le cadre de cette enquête
là il y a rien qui aurait empêché juste
un truc d'autre faire la même chose avec
Monsieur Johnston en fait ça aurait
probablement marché mais maintenant je
suis d'accord avec Alex c'est comme si
Justin Trudeau avait dit le train de
cette enquête publique a quitté la gare
malgré moi je ne peux pas l'arrêter
alors je vais lancer monsieur Johnston
sur la voie voir il fait écraser à ma
place parce qu'il y a pas le train
c'est pas un rôle particulier
est-ce que Michel est-ce que ça est-ce
que est-ce que il y a encore une option
là-dedans pour le gouvernement de calmer
le jeu est-ce que ça peut encore faire
baisser la pression qui semblait être
énorme en début de la semaine dernière
il a mis un autre délai un délai
supplémentaire là-dedans au moment où on
est rendu dans l'année on risque d'avoir
la décision de Monsieur Johnson proche
de la fin de la session parlementaire ou
peut-être même après la journée de la
femme ça serait bien son affaire ça peut
arriver beaucoup plus tôt aussi mais je
veux dire on est même pas dans une façon
de calmer le jeu ils vont il va avoir
des événements
enlever un peu de pression mais ça va
revenir ça s'en va pas la question de
l'interférence chinoise c'est trop
sérieux on n'a pas vu de menace à la
démocratie canadienne comme ça ça
aussi sérieuse depuis très très
longtemps alors c'est sûr que ça s'en
ira pas j'entends rapidement
au fil des fuites ça gagne la politique
provinciale qui est arrivé en Ontario
dans le caucus de Monsieur Ford c'est la
politique municipale avant couvert qui
met le maire élu dans l'embarras ce qui
est quand même pas une petite chose pour
la Colombie Britannique quand vous êtes
tout ça la seule bonne nouvelle pour les
libéraux jusqu'à présent c'est que ça
fait pas vraiment bouger
l'aiguille des intentions de vote selon
moi en partie parce que Parti
conservateur monsieur Pellier sont allés
beaucoup trop loin et vont beaucoup trop
loin dans leur façon de plaider la cause
d'une enquête publique encore une fois
cette semaine en faisant un procès
on va s'arrêter là-dessus sur ce sujet
là parce que clairement on n'a pas fini
d'en parler ça va revenir dans les
prochaines semaines alex je vous
entendre sur là on va faire un peu de
projection premier budget du second
mandat de la CAQ Monsieur Girard qui
dépose ce mardi
qu'est-ce que vous voulez voir là-dedans
quoi vous vous attendez de l'exercice de
Monsieur Girard
je m'attends à ce que le gouvernement
respecte les baisses d'impôts qui leur
promise en campagne électorale même s'il
y a des critiques assez nombreuses qui
disent qu'on devrait peut-être utiliser
ces deux milliards là de dollars par
année à d'autres fins donc ça je pense
que ça va être dans le budget c'est une
promesse on va pas y renoncer on a même
fait une partie de la campagne
électorale d'ancien Henri 50 avec des
pancartes en baisse d'impôts 2023 je
m'entends pas ce que le ministre Girard
recule là-dessus pour le reste
l'émission importante de l'État
l'éducation la santé vont avoir des
budgets on sera pas dans l'austérité on
sera pas dans les restrictions mais je
m'attends pas à d'autres feux d'artifice
je pense que le gouvernement veut
montrer un peu comme on va le faire
Ottawa la semaine suivante une certaine
rigueur budgétaire ne pas ajouter à
l'inflation ambiante montrer qu'on gère
bien les finances publiques et peut-être
une récession qui s'en vient donc on va
pas dépenser à tout vendre disons on
sait pas ce qui s'en vient
éventuellement pas oublier que Gérard
est un conservateur à la base c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas dépensé plus
qu'il ne le faut et là je pense qu'il a
le mandat de donner ce qu'il faut un peu
à tout le monde mais de ne pas en faire
plus que le client demande donc un
budget qui va respecter quand même un
cadre assez serré puis je m'attends un
peu à la même chose de Christophe
Freeland donc pas de grande surprise je
pense que ça va être un budget assez
prévisible donc Michel puis ensuite
Chantal là-dessus
c'est Gérard est un conservateur vient
de dire Alex c'est vrai je pense que le
conservateur en lui les ferait pas les
belles impôts à ce moment-ci mais que
c'est une commande politique du premier
ministre après tout il s'est fait tenir
là-dessus alors il veut il veut remplir
son mandat de la même façon que Monsieur
Gérard est allé faire une réforme des
pensions mais aussi chez cette semaine
mais que son premier ministre lui a dit
non non ça passe pas cette idée de faire
attendre des gens à 62 ans pour pouvoir
commencer à prendre le régime des rentes
et Monsieur Girard c'était exécuté alors
c'est un budget on vient aux promesses
on brasse-moi la cage et on finance
correctement dans la mesure du possible
les les grandes missions de l'état de
s'en faire de l'austérité des coupures
dans celui du Québec les baisses
d'impôts ça c'est ce qu'on verra
vraisemblablement pas en tout cas pas
cette échelle là dans le budget de la
semaine suivante à Ottawa dans celui du
Québec par contre c'est l'argent du
fédéral pour la santé qui va rentrer et
qui allait rentrer de toute façon de
façon assez importante à cause de
l'inflation mais autrement j'ai comme
l'impression que c'est pas un budget qui
va faire jaser vraiment longtemps mais
contrairement celui de la semaine
suivante la survie du gouvernement
dépend pas un autre événement qu'on va
surveiller la semaine prochaine quelques
jours après deux jours après le budget
de Monsieur Girard c'est l'arrivée au
Canada monsieur Baden pour la première
visite en personne on va parler
d'économie on va parler des milliers de
migration irrégulière Michel je commence
avec vous quel comment comment on mesure
le succès de ce sommet
il faut justement pas avoir une une
liste de choses à cocher dans un sommet
comme celui-là parce qu'on va toujours
être déçu c'est les gens s'attendent par
exemple parce qu'on règle le chemin
Roxane pendant les 36 heures monsieur
Biden va être Ottawa ça se fera pas
comme ça d'ailleurs c'est assez amusant
de voir la liste que publier la Maison
Blanche quand ils ont donné l'agenda de
la visite l'immigration est régulière
était au septième et dernier rang de
abordé alors peut-être ça donne une idée
de combien c'est important pour la
partie américaine en tout cas mais quand
deux chefs d'État du G7 se rencontrent
il parle pas juste de leur problème
réciproques il parle aussi de la
situation internationale c'est clair que
la situation en Ukraine le voyage que le
président chinois va faire à Moscou la
semaine prochaine va être alors du jour
peut-être bien plus que les irritants de
la de la frontière nord des États-Unis
on vient de parler à quel point Justin
Trudeau est un peu fragilisé par toute
l'histoire de l'ingérence chinoise je ne
m'attends pas donc qu'est-ce qu'on fasse
monter les attentes pour risquer d'avoir
un mauvais sommet je pense qu'au
contraire on a besoin de bonnes
nouvelles et tout se passe bien je pense
que Joe ballerine qui est un démocrate
qui est assez pré philosophiquement de
Justin Trudeau va pas faire non plus
exprès alors je m'attend pas ce que de
grandes nouvelles qui sortent on va
parler d'économie on va parler de
coopération en environnement on est sur
la même longueur d'onde pour l'Ukraine
ce sera des sujets assez tarte aux
pommes si je puis dire dans la mesure où
tout le monde va probablement s'entendre
je pense qu'on va parler d'immigration
irrégulière je ne pense pas que ça va
faire partie du communiqué final je ne
pense pas qu'on va avoir une annonce à
faire je pense qu'on va en parler parce
que il y a peut-être un rôle que le
Canada pourrait jouer parce que les
Américains essaient d'améliorer les
conditions de vie des pays où
l'immigration pousse vers les États-Unis
là en Amérique latine en Amérique
centrale je pense que Joe baiden
voudrait bien que le Canada fasse donne
un coup de main dans ces pays-là pour
améliorer les conditions de vie de
l'aide internationale ainsi de suite on
va en parler de manière générale je
pense pas qu'il va y avoir quelque chose
de très particulier va pas régler je
suis d'accord avec Michel le chemin avec
Sam la semaine prochaine
des progrès sur le chemin Roxane mais
Joe Biden aimerait que le Canada se
commette à envoyer des forces de
sécurité en Haïti dans un cas comme dans
l'autre ça arrivera vraisemblablement
pas il y a un sujet que tout le monde
surveille et c'est toujours le même
c'est celui du protectionnisme américain
et l'idée que les projets ou la loi
anti-inflation de Joe Biden c'est
certaines de ces dispositions où il est
question seulement de d'Amérique comme
dans États-Unis soyez élargi comme dans
le cas du marché automobile pour parler
de Canada Etats-Unis des fautes parlées
d'Amérique du Nord on va surveiller donc
le côté économique davantage puis on
verra ce qui se passe du côté de Roxane
migration irrégulière avec Chantal
Michel merci d'avoir été là à dimanche
prochain au revoir